[Musik]
ein luzerner unternehmer kämpft um seine
firma corona bringt das unternehmen zum
stillstand
eine künstlerin muss alles absagen
denn ist so dass drei lohn haben coruna
gefährdet ihre existenz sozialstunden
worden luzerns größter souvenirhändler
ist fassungslos märz vorstellen
es war der touristen hotspot es klar wir
sind wir kaputt war und zwei luzerner
freunde betreiben ein hotel
sie geben alles um das haus zu retten
ihre geschichten in luzern in corona ja
[Musik]
es ist sommer
drei monate nach den schatten im
frühjahr 2020 bemühen sich die menschen
in luzern um normalität
die maßnahmen wurden gelockert und man
sehen sich nach dem leben wie er es vor
corona war in willisau bereiten die
mitarbeitenden des größten zeltmeister
schweiz der firma hunziker ein grillfest
vor mitten in der schlimmsten krise des
85-jährigen unternehmens wegen corona
sind alle großen events abgesagt jetzt
will sie roland kind die belegschaft
nicht allein lassen
die 70 mitarbeitenden des kmu sind in
kurzarbeit die meisten zu hause
umso mehr genießen sie das wiedersehen
schulter an schulter und masken frei wie
im juni 2020 üblich herzlichen dank dass
du so schaurig schöner senderwechsel
freut konnte so großzügig
ich garantiere ich dass mich die
geschäftsleitung tut und holly setzte
wechsel für euch dass man die firma am
leben erhalten lasse gesicherten
arbeitsplatz und irgendwann große sorge
ist dass der andere vielleicht
irgendwann zeit sonnig nur mit der
heimat kritik und die wenigstens
geschaffen oder und das hobby einfach
nicht dass das tv show zweiter und rufe
jeden vorgang jetzt am grill und der
ganze ist aber noch ein individuell und
selbständige
[Applaus]
der chef persönlich steht am grill nur
die schürze fehlt zu den fröschen finde
das schlechte gewissen aufkommen
welcher doch obwohl er unwirsch
das für mich genau gegenüber von der
mitarbeiter erhöht wirtschaftsleitung
und blüht soliden ersetzen und bedient
war
der 50-jährige hat die leitung der firma
vor zweieinhalb jahren übernommen
der gelernte käser und maurer scheint
bei der belegschaft den richtigen ton zu
treffen
ein großes versprechen in so unsicheren
zeiten beim team kommt das an
philipp steuert die großen trucks jetzt
nutzt er die freie zeit für radtouren
gerade in der krise sollen die
angestellten spüren dass der chef hinter
ihnen steht
doch das ausmaß der krise diese zogen
mehr und mehr sorge bereiten
[Musik]
in der touristenstadt luzern bleiben im
sommer 2020 die gäste aus dem ausland
weg
die logiernächte sind eingebrochen
eine luzerner hotelgruppe streicht über
100 stellen eine massenentlassung
auch den gut hotel bosse steht das
wasser bis zum hals es kommen zwar
vermehrt schweizerinnen und schweizer
aber nur bei schönem wetter manuel
berger ist froh um jeden gast
anders als im letzten sommer werden
zimmer storniert oder gar nicht erst
gebucht musik des 18
[Musik]
manuel berger für das buch gemeinsam mit
seinem geschäftspartner walter willi
bieli man russland und dass gott immer
so und das gott sehr schnell
du musst office i und der mieter auf die
- also dass das kam es nach 3456 die
besucher erleben und echte der schau
eine kredit für den bund also mit
friends and family am wochenende
übernachtet überlebt nehmen aber hey von
der schweizer der la carte hotellerie
nicht lassen sich um möglichen will der
schweizer hat möglichkeit zu schwach um
mit mietwagen was laut sagen da
vielleicht lieber schlafen wenn man ab
dem spektakel ist oben halter sofort
laden die stadt tourismus komplett
gesetzt hat und nicht wie bei brake oder
bis 1 grad in was ihre eltern auch der
schweizer zeit gesperrt ist das kommt
uns jetzt nicht ganz gut
der bund unterstützt die branche mit 40
millionen franken hilfsgeldern die
hälfte für marketingmaßnahmen
aber dieses video löst bei den hoteliers
keine begeisterung aus
mai braucht für dich und deine lieben
denn aus der schweiz
natur natur
das heißt also ich das antifa der
stadthotellerie wie das haus vor der
schließung bewahren
ratlosigkeit macht sich breit
eine touristenstadt ohne ausländische
gäste
[Musik]
das trifft lizenz trösten
souvenirhändler mitten ins herz
und doch gibt sich robert casagrande
umtriebig wie eh und je
[Musik]
im casa grande stammhaus herrscht flaute
wir schon viel zu tun gehabt da eine
reparatur von meinem freund ich musste
am dienstag mitnehmen
ich finde das geld sonst war es noch
ruhig heute morgen gut aber das ist
natürlich nicht wie vor corona war das
geschäft dank chinesischen und indischen
reisegruppen eine goldgrube ist
[Musik]
da muss wir sind europa zurück meint
eshaqi einfach auf und mit 50 prozent
rabatt
das hat damit zu tun dass die schoki
entweder ende juni abgelaufen ist oder
juli abläuft normalerweise sind das
tempo ist die beste und das m für
schokolade
sie nahmen mit also sagt wyss aber wenn
jetzt in der haupttäter april mai juni
juli überlagert habe die handlung von 20
mal im moment noch am lager und abbau
uhr bis im nächsten januar
[Musik]
zur mutter für die händler ist die kasse
bei das ist geschichte von ihnen ältere
wo das geschäft eröffnet händen in 248
und mini 3 mit 80 franken auffangen
ich habe gewusst dass ich das nicht
machen
ich bin
eigentlich geborene verkäufe mit 16 gb
schotterbett die verkäuferin pause am
engagement auf und habe weiß dass ich
mir die zukunft automatisch ausgeschafft
zwei mal mit brille darüber nach
mit erfolg die beiden brüder wir sitzen
heute in der ganzen stadt fünf filialen
und mehrere liegenschaften und im
zweiten stock sind toilette erhalt
natürlicher grund wieso im zweiten stock
damit läutete oder ganz neu aber laufen
und es beglückend die toilette geht es
natürlich eine möglichkeit heißt es
danke für die chinese die macht
teilwiese iii geht das oberdeck linie
kreismitteln die natürlich auf haufen im
notfall wenn sie es nicht hatte und er
braucht sie heißes wasser und das ganze
bewusst anke doch die chinesen bleiben
schon seit januar 2020 aus 100 und sechs
angestellte sind in kurzarbeit
es tut weh aber ich kann es nicht
anderen und was nützt mir das wenn ich
begonnen und zur liebe und ich muss ja
minute motivieren und ich bin ein
optimistischer mensch
[Musik]
noch im rennen sondern
bei der firma hunziker in willisau steht
fast alles still
nur der werkhof chef bewegt ab und zu
die lastwagen umstand schäden zu
vermeiden
die polizei kennt noch mit denen
nachgegangen und der hey mann jetzt so
ist noch wie der neue geschäftsführer
roland king setzt die situation zu in
diesen zeiten plant niemand ein event
die festzelte bleiben im lager da hilft
auch der bundes kredit von bisher
500.000 franken wenig
[Musik]
absolut die hochs ohne das würde nur in
ganz anders zu und die sponsoren und
personal gesprochen wolf temperaturen
machen ist und ja die lütten alle daheim
sind mal wieder ein
zudem bringen die geschäftsleitung auf
dass der bundesrat grossanlässe über
1000 personen bald wieder zulässt der
bundesratsjet widersteht ich musste mir
wichtig dass es so kurz für hardcore die
neuesten zahlen
204 selbst kein zug mehr mit rufen wie
horst gar nicht dass kurz für und
ehrlichkeit der leiter für logistik
philipp wasser wurde kurz vor den
schatten gestellt
auch er hofft auf eine lockerung um
endlich arbeiten zu können
[Musik]
das verbot einen monat zu verlängern
danach können die kantone grossanlässe
strecken bietet das quiz das heißt es
ist ein besonders stolz
das ist gerade fertig machen wir sowohl
im moment macht mir sorge um erwähnte
die strang unter strengen auflagen oder
das dass ich für eine situation vor
erwähnt nicht umsetzbar ist
hinweis für die firma und die
belegschaft könnte das große
konsequenzen haben situation finanzielle
momente so dass man noch monat irgendwo
zwischen 52 300 350 franken - nicht der
ganz grosse 1000 personalkosten oder
natürlich konkret spricht es an personal
know me aber sprechen klassiker
natürlich persönlich vielleicht liebe
rührte bis drei jahren die scheine das
ganze immer extrem optimistisch gemeinde
im grünen gras ist wieder gordon roland
seitz im herbst ich mir sicher dass es
wieder geordnet
das auto sei das tag in serie ruhen
sicherer und hessisches bilder gott zu
mir über das holz bin ich nur noch eines
mehr verunsichert bemühen da irgendwie
ihr dollar
der logistikchef startete bei hunziker
im november 2009 10
kaum angekommen traf ihn der shutter und
mit voller wucht
jetzt so der erfahrene meerkat der
verdacht jahre geschichte und da hat mir
natürlich mit stolz danach hat ihre
funktion deutschland übernahm roland
könig sein lockeres 3 minute 70 jahre
weiter und den gast erst richtig los
und dann ist da noch der co
[Musik]
da muss ich realistisch und sage
eigentlich sogar 350 stellen
ja gut möglich
[Musik]
das bringt immer so angesprochen und
können hofft noch immer dass einige der
geplanten events durchgeführt werden
aber die unsicherheit ist groß kann mir
vorstellen dass der spengler cup
stattfindet peter vaillant arena ist
eigentlich dominiert aber was roma
weltrekord sprechstunde auftrag das
nicht sagt und wenn ich nach rio de
janeiro josé silva tenders wef in davos
wef international wechsel in den
rallyesport bruchs an seine grenzen habe
zu konzepten chronik bearbeiten klicken
nicht optimistisch das versprechen an
seine mitarbeitenden dass sie
weihnachten mit einem sicheren job
feiern kennen scheint in immer weitere
ferne zu rücken
[Musik]
dem sommer hindurch läuft der
hotelbetrieb in brusio recht ordentlich
dank der schweizer gäste die fast alle
im eigenen land ferien machen
an diesem wochenende sind alle 28 zimmer
des hotels bonjour ausgebucht vier
luzerner lassen zu ihrem dreißigsten
geburtstag eine party steigen und haben
das ganze hotel für zwei tage gemietet
haben wir das natürlich schön dass man
den händen
das ist super gestartet ist ein großes 5
wenn dass wir praktisch schon diverse
reformen und so
[Musik]
um das fest ausrichten zu können hat
manuel berger service fachleute dazu
gemietet
kein aufwand ist ihm zu groß 85 gäste
sollen hier speisen und feiern können
die aktuellen krone regeln lassen das zu
allerdings muss um mitternacht schluss
sein
[Musik]
für die geburtstagskinder war es eine
zitterpartie
lange war unklar ob das fest im großen
rahmen stattfinden kann wenn du
unbedingt diese heimatstadt die nutzer
spezielle machen
schlussendlich hamilton dankt ich hoffe
alle schön wie das lied normalität
zurück zu sein das kurz konzept
aufgestellt und mit reggae party am rand
fertig machen
[Musik]
trotz aller vorfreude spürt manuel auch
eine leise unsicherheit kleine an strom
ist das so als stecke geweitet natürlich
nicht gut für israel etwas voran trainer
machen und so was einzelne hotels oder
einzelne quartiere in quarantäne setzte
das gar nicht so abschließen die sorge
ist nicht unbegründet
erst kürzlich wurde der erste fall eines
super sprechers bekannt
[Musik]
am see taal platz in emmenbrücke machen
sich musikerin claudia kienzler und
christoph spielmann an die
renovationsarbeiten am varieté
kaleidoskop claudia hat es im januar
übernommen dann kam der shutter und die
tournee pläne sind gefährdet die beiden
sind seit gut einem jahr ein paar
[Musik]
wir können sich so sind decken und das
funktioniert nicht abblocken sondern 75
schaffte zum sie ausprobieren und ihnen
eine chance dass das irgendwie die
balance stimmt das ist immer direkt
tiefer als die anderen person und dort
seine studie habe nicht nur die varietät
toni von 2021 ist in frage gestellt
wegen corona wurden alle konzerte der
profi geigerin abgesagt das los vieler
kulturschaffenden
auch in der musik bei meyers mussten
konzerte abgesagt oder verschoben werden
betreiber dominic meier steht hinter der
bar dominik für die bar zusammen mit
keiner frau fiona während des shutdown
war ihr betrieb wochen lang geschlossen
aber es ist also langfristig sie mit
einer frage macht sich selbst haben
bereits abgesagt
bei krakau und das ist schon cool stuff
schon mit madonna ist eine frau bei
extrem existenz und dann ist irgendwas
aufgelaufenen zeitdruck nicht angebaut
eine situation dann seid ihr jetzt bei
stadt yamada nichts nichts
gerade nicht unbedingt einfach fest dass
das normale dominik ist drummer der
luzerner kund band mothers pride nach
zehn jahren planten sie auf den frühling
ein comeback jetzt hoffen sie auf den
herbst
[Musik]
recke
mittlerweile geht es im hotel bosse so
hoch zu und her
die geburtstagsparty macht manuel berger
und seinem team hoffnung auf bessere
zeiten
[Musik]
in saerbeck sie sind und sogar 86
vier frauen
gäste bewirten und beherbergen das ist
manuels leidenschaft
die apéro häppchen hat der gelernte koch
selbst gemacht
das abendessen wird von einem
befreundeten koch zubereitet
[Musik]
wie hoch ist das halbe leben also
vorbereitet
china bleibt für marseille
diese fotos werden manuell an einen
sommer erinnern der besser war als
erwartet
[Musik]
ahaus und die terrasse voller gäste
claudia kienzler auf dem weg zur arbeit
weil hier alle konzerte weggebrochen
sind ist jetzt flexibilität gefragt
genau wie bei ihrem kollegen sandro er
hat einen take away eröffnet
[Musik]
gleich auf sechs
sandro hat sich vom arbeitslosen
barbetreiber zum vielbeschäftigten
tk-anbieter gewandelt essen zum
mitnehmen passt in die korona welt und
das hat natürlich weniger ausschüsse
geschaffen und auch bei der neu erfinden
ist ist das auch okay
auch die 39 jährige violinistin claudia
muss in diesen zeiten beweglich bleiben
ein engagement für eine
theaterproduktion gibt er eine
perspektive für den herbst
[Musik]
hatte einen harten tag seine beiden
kinder bringen ihn auf andere gedanken
und schönen schnitt sohn jannik will
mediamatiker werden
heute war er schnuppern so aber war am
morgen 20 also sichergestellt und
interesse für das gute was mach ich
jetzt
jetzt ja mit einer mit einer meiner
motive wohnbereich und weil sich mein
vater bist gm zurück geschrieben und
dann von einer besonders bist du bist
koloman er sterbe vom in scannern und
friedliches meile also männer mit der
leistung in dem es durch die sehr
bedanken weil das eine abnahme gut
vorstellen ex bewerbungsgespräch und
diese in trance sich nach wie vor
ungebrochen großen durch sehr freuen
wenn du kleben deftig mag so läuft aus
du wirst du da bist der wird aber dabei
spielt natürlich gut vorbereitete sauber
müssen vorbereitet und ich habe mir
wirklich in frage gestellt und ich hatte
der potenzielle lehrmeister sport und
dem fragen gestellt und das aber sehr
sehr gut gemacht
euro vor sowie fertig sprechen so gesagt
was ihr und absagen und so was ich sage
sogar kurz seine scheidung der eltern
liegen länder und jannik bei der mutter
gleich um die ecke
so sind sie auch oft bei ihrem vater
familie wichtig hierbei mini band über
rohners christi immer ob es ist
natürlich jetzt noch gerade noch mal
gehört gott natürlich einfacher zu
merken abschaut das wird sofort antreten
unbeschwerter wenn sie nicht toleriert
wenn ihr leben studiert natürlich den
dohlen also auch genommen und über
leicht aus und dieses und die stadt als
positives der wechsel ganz genau wann
aber und schon irgendwann mischte
nachtruhe und den kopf kommen sehr viele
skigebiete
am sonntag feiert linda erstkommunion in
der kirche wird sie auf der blockflöte
vorspielen
eine volle kirche und ein familienfest
im sommer 2020 ist das noch möglich
im kleintheater luzern soll in vier
monaten premiere gefeiert werden
vor richtigen publikum claudia kienzler
ist froh um dieses engagement
die musikerin hat auch als darstellerin
erfahrung so hat sie auch schon mit
regisseur christoph marthaler gearbeitet
die schauspieler proben für eine
musikalische kinder geschichte über das
leben die freundschaft und den tod
16 wie trikots dem vorschlag darum habe
ich mich wohlfühle
die handlung eine enthemmung sterben
doch als sie den tod trifft werden die
beiden unerwartet freuen
in corona zeiten wo das sterben
unverhoffte präsenz erhält gewinnt auch
das stück an aktualität
die proben haben eben erst begonnen
[Musik]
die welt sieht dass da wieder ruhig das
ist alles improvisiert das ist nicht
abgemacht es ist nicht die studie jetzt
dass ich noch nie gesetzt das ist
sammler von material und möglichkeiten
luca wiegt das machen woran sie sind
vorüber grenze drüber und dann hat man
wieder neue erkenntnisse besonders
gebraucht
die premiere ist auf erster november
geplant aber ob sie stattfinden kann ist
noch völlig offen
einen solchen sommer hat luzern noch nie
erlebt die fehlenden touristen
hinterlassen tiefe spuren
die souvenir geschäfte bleiben nähe für
beuern den hauswart bei casagrande gibt
es denn noch unterhaltsarbeiten zu
erledigen
der chef sieht sich nach dem trubel der
vergangenheit
[Musik]
die krise trifft viele unternehmen auch
der traditionsreiche schiffsbetrieb
buche sitzt auf dem trockenen
die polemiken oder wenn die drei
internationale touristen
das ist er sieben kinder
bald ist der sommer vorbei dann werden
auch die schweizer touristen wegbleiben
darum hat robert casagrande keine guten
nachrichten für die angestellten der
filiale beim löwendenkmal dass die
heimische richtet die stadt und denkt
mal aber wir haben diese entschloss so
dass man am 15 august wieder zu machen
sich immer besser mit
september müssen aber beweise sind sauer
nicht so gut ist dass vorgestellten
bis bald nach wochen nicht am
mittwochmorgen bei aktien und der mit
sohn und ein hut samt ja auch irgendwie
gebe mir dass mir da allgemein die
situation aber mit dem feedback vom
oberen geschäftsleitung und die geht
dann auch noch den halt und drehen sich
viel und dann kurz nach aber ich glaube
seit glied wohl schlimmer tapferkeit
in der nächsten folge
die krise hat für souvenirhändler
casagrande große auswirkungen sind im
sommer für ehe variete muss claudia
kienzler dringend geld auftreiben
riesige investition leichter wo jetzt
irgendwer und roland kühn brecht sein
versprechen an die belegschaft
[Musik]
schlecht